hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute gibt es einen wunsch rezept
denn viele von euch haben sich von mir
windbeutel gewünscht allerdings macht
keine windbeutel sondern erklärt
erklärten solange stäbchen sag ich jetzt
mal auch liebes knochen genannt und ich
werde heute film mit einer italienischen
creme meine freunde war nämlich vor
kurzem daum hat mehr windbeutel mit
dieser italienischen creme gebracht da
habe ich gedacht mensch windbeutel will
ich eigentlich mal klassisch machen mit
sahne deswegen gibt es heute erklären
mit einer italienischen vanillecreme und
ich zeige euch jetzt einfach mal direkt
die zutaten für die creme und auch
direkt für den brand steht also für die
windbeutel windbeutel sind wirklich
nicht schwer zu machen beziehungsweise
der brand steigt aber viele haben angst
vorm ich weiß eigentlich ehrlich gesagt
nicht warum aber ich zeige euch jetzt
einfach mal schnell die zutaten also für
die creme brauchen wir 250 milliliter
milch 3 eigelb 25 gramm speisestärke 75
gramm zucker und vanille und für den
brand tag brauchen wir 60 gramm butter
250 milliliter wasser eine prise salz
200 gramm mehl und etwa drei bis vier
eier wobei bei mir die eier jetzt groß
sind also größe l deswegen benutze ich
jetzt erstmal nur drei kann aber auch
sein dass ihr verbrauch je nach je
nachdem wie groß sehen sind zuerst
müssen wir jetzt mal die creme
herstellen denn die wird jetzt gleich
gekocht und muss dann abkühlen und
danach stellen wir dann den brand teig
er zuerst geben wir jetzt die milch in
einen kleinen topf hier ja alles rein
wenn man jetzt einfach alle zutaten
denn daraus wird jetzt erstmal ein
putting gebracht und wer möchte kann
übrigens statt der vanille auch
zitronenschale mit rein geben oder
einfach andere aromen und die creme
heisst soviel ich weiss klimadiplomatie
gelb noch mit rein
dann wird es jetzt alles schön verrührt
das ist eben kümmert klümpchen frei ist
das stufen quatchi neben mir links aus
und dann kommts weg super ich gehe jetzt
auch manila
da können das schon ganz schön viel rein
geben denn es soll eine richtig leckere
vanillecreme werden
jetzt stelle ich den herd auf mittlere
stufe und das ganze jetzt aufkochen dann
musst du aufpassen dass euch das amt oft
roten nicht anbrennt und auch nicht
überkocht deswegen immer auf mittlerer
stufe unterrühren
die creme ist schön eingedeckt und die
fülle ich jetzt oben
damit sie eben schön abkühlen kann sie
kann man übrigens zum beispiel auch mit
schokolade machen oder jetzt in richtung
weihnachten und winter mit orange aber
ich hab mich für vanille entschieden
denn ihr wisst was ich bei mir so eine
grundzutat zu hause gegen ganz klassisch
heute das mach ich kurz jetzt täglich
direkt mit der folie ab direkt an der
oberfläche damit die claims keiner
hautbildes weil die später beim
ansonsten ganz harter kampf und die
kredit stelle jetzt kurz zur seite und
kann jetzt in denen topf meinen brand
teig zubereiten
dafür gebe ich jetzt wasser und butter
und eine prise salz in einem großen topf
und es muss jetzt erst einmal aufkochen
jetzt kocht die mischung auf und ich
schalte im herzen aus jetzt gebe ich das
mehl in einem schwung mit dazu und es
müsste jetzt ganz gut durchrühren da
wird es gleich ein großer teil
und jetzt wenn sich alles gut verbunden
hat schaltet dem herd wieder ein und
muss jetzt den teig erstmal abbrennen
das heißt ich spüre jetzt etwa noch 12
minuten bis sich am topfboden an weißer
belag gebildet hat deswegen heißt dieser
tag auch brand weil man dann abbrennt
also es ist kein schwieriges rezept aber
es ist sehr kräfteraubend zu sagen also
brandtag herzustellen
mit der hand also dann kochen wir
vielleicht schon ziemlich anstrengend
und so sieht an dieser weise belag auf
dem boden aus jetzt kann ich den herd
ausschalten und den teig aus verrät
ruhig wie sie verrät studie hat recht
ist uns bisher angebrannt aber das ist
nicht schlimm weil wir nehmen denn jetzt
täglich raus soll ich mich doch nicht
verpetzen jetzt für dich diesem tag oben
in eine große schüssel und jetzt können
die entweder mit dem löffel weitermachen
also einem bug löffel einem kochlöffel
oder ihr macht jetzt einfach mit der
küchenmaschine weiter
ich habe letztes mal schaumlöffel
weitergemacht aber ich muss sagen es ist
sehr anstrengend und heute spare ich mir
das so macht es jetzt eben mit der
küchenmaschine mit dem flacherer und
jetzt müsst ihr einen nach dem anderen
unter rühren erstmal das erste und es
muss sich erst richtig gut verbinden bis
dann das nächste dazu kommt und am
anfang sieht wirklich so aus als wird
sich der teig nie verbinden zu einem
homogenen teig und auch wenn man das mit
der hand wird das ist am anfang ziemlich
deprimierend aber ihr müsst einfach
immer ständig weiterbilden das wird ein
richtig schöner glänzen datei
das hkz fertig bin richtig schöne farbe
und glänzt auch richtig toll
also man sieht es auch wenn man den
umfeld richtig schöne spitzen auf und
ich finde ihn jetzt in einen
spritzbeutel da habe ich schon eine
stelle vorne dran eine ganz große
ich glaube mir 13 mm stern kühl ist es
und den brand tag geben immer ganz gern
ein weg spritzbeutel weil danach das
saubermachen einfach etwas schwieriger
wäre bzw
es riecht dann halt manchmal ziemlich
nach 1 deswegen nehme ich am liebsten
ein mix spritzbeutel
da oben wird er spritzbeutel jetzt schon
zugedreht
und jetzt können wir die eclair schon
auf spritzen und zwar müssen immer
darauf achten dass die eine hand hinten
das wirklich schön zu hält denn der teig
ist ziemlich fest damit euch das einfach
hinten nicht wieder raus spritzt mit
spritze ich einfach so etwa zehn
zentimeter lange strenge die sollten
möglichst gleich dick sein damit auch
gleichmäßig durch backen
jetzt werden die erklären noch mit etwas
wasser bepinselt
wir werden die erkläre im vorgeheizten
backofen bei 200 grad ober und
unterhitze für ungefähr 30 minuten
gebacken
kann auch sein dass nur 25 minuten sind
auf jeden fall müsst ihr darauf achten
was sie während dem backen den backofen
auf keinen fall öffnen denn ansonsten
fällt euch das gepäck zusammen und
lieber lastet etwas länger drin als zu
kurz denn wenn sie zu kurz gebacken
werden und innen nicht ganz durch sind
dann fallen sich nach dem backen
zusammen
also ich schieb setzte dann offen und
wenn sie ganz fertig sind zeige ich euch
dann das ergebnis erkläre sind jetzt
gebacken und ich habe sie bereits auf
dem abkühlen gitter gesetzt und damit
jetzt schneller und besser abkühlen
können werde ich jetzt einmal in der
mitte durchschneiden und zwar geht es am
besten mit einem brotmesser und dann
legt das ja auch am besten so offen
gehen dann können wir endlich richtig
schön ausdampfen
und während die ehcler jetzt hier noch
abkühlen kann ich schon mal den pudding
durch einen sieg streichen
so kommen eben eventuell klümpchen noch
mit raus
als nächstes nehme ich jetzt 200 gramm
kalte schlagsahne und schlagt die mit
zwei teelöffeln seiner partei und dann
wird es eben mit der creme vermengt
jetzt kann man den pudding bereits in
die sahne einrühren
aber das mache ich jetzt gleich noch mal
mit dem schneebesen
die creme fühle ich jetzt in einen
spritzbeutel mit stern thüle also die
gleiche wie vor hin und dann stelle ich
sie noch mal ganz kurz kühl bis eben die
erkläre auch schön kalt sind
jetzt kann ich die ecke mit der creme
gefüllt
m
und dann könnt ihr die decke schön drauf
setzen
die r klasse jetzt so eigentlich schon
fertig das heißt ihr könnt jetzt auch so
schon servieren mit etwas puderzucker
oder süßen schnee bestreuen und dann
eben schön anrichten
aber ich finde auf die erklärt gehört
auch noch eine schöne schokoladen
schicht deswegen brauche ich jetzt noch
zwei zutaten und zwar 100 bilder
schokolade und 50 gramm sahne und das
ist jetzt wie eine organisch also ich
muss jetzt einmal kurz die sahne
aufkochen und dann kann man die
schokolade gleich einrühren und darin
schmelzen
und jetzt könnt ihr die erklärung mit
der schokolade bestreifen
die kers sind jetzt fertig und
eigentlich muss man jetzt auch noch mal
kühl stellen das mache ich jetzt auch
gleich aber der murat darf jetzt
trotzdem schon mal probieren und am
besten mache das jetzt einfach so in die
hand und weiß einfach rein
ich habe persönlich gewissen soll ja ich
hab das auch noch nie gemacht ich habe
immer nur windbeutel gemacht bisher und
eine manuelle gräben yao ist eine
mischung zwischen den wind bolzen ein
mohrenkopf wegen der schokolade
bescheiden lesen ja also die creme kann
man abwandeln wie man möchte
ich mag sie ganz gerne wenn in der creme
statt vanille zitronenschale mit drin
ist dann schmeckt einfach noch ein
bisschen frischer und fruchtiger aber
dann finde ich fast keine schokolade
oben drauf als ich hier heute die
klassische version wird super und wenn
der morath möchte können wir gerne auch
noch mal die zitronige reste und machen
nicht perfekt also ich stelle jetzt noch
markant wenn ihr sie nach machen wollt
geht einfach auf meinem blog auf cds -
blog.de da steht noch mal die genauen
zutaten angaben
und ich finde es inhaltlich gut aus und
man kann sogar die ecke einfrieren bevor
man sie fühlt als ihr könnt sie
aufschneiden abkühlen lassen einfrieren
und bei bedarf auftauen und daneben
füllen und dekorieren und servieren
finde ich eine ganz gute sache weil ich
meinen zu 16 erklärt sind schon ziemlich
viel
also ich bin jetzt da muss man jetzt
wieder an die nachbarschaft verteilt die
freude sich naja von miranshah wieso
gerade dort dann kann ich gleich vom
abholen ein paar erklärt mit abgeben
das passt ganz gut also bis zum nächsten
mal viel spaß beim nachbacken